At this point, your share gif
method should be in place and
connected to the share button.
So your app might look
something like this.
Here's a video of my coworker,
who I accosted while she
was looking at her data.
I add a caption, and
now I can text it to my teammate.
And you can see that in the text
message it appears as a GIF.
So now, we can check off Share the GIF.
Next step, convert a video
from the album into a GIF.
In order to convert a video
from the album into a GIF,
you'll need to create an action
sheet that has three options.
Record a video.
Choose from existing videos.
And cancel.
To enable the option to
choose from that album,
you'll need to write a method
that launches the photo library.
So let's move on to
create an action sheet.